i'm gonna make a case to you today why i
believe gas prices in the next 24 months
could potentially go to ten dollars per
gallon and yes that's what i believe ten
dollars per gallon
next 24 months based on a lot of
different factors if you agree with my
argument once i make it
smash the thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel if you don't put a thumbs down
i'm okay i want to kind of see
how you feel about this by the way we're
going to look at the following data in
today's video number one
we're going to look at which country gas
prices are the most expensive as well as
cheap
we're going to look at which countries
have the most ev electric vehicles
being driven and is there a correlation
between countries that are fully going
green
and high gas prices because they're
trying to influence people from not
driving
gasoline-powered cars we'll look at gas
prices the most in city
states and we'll look at uh consumption
we'll look at uh
many different data as well as auto
manufacturers are they going away from
gasoline
powered cars so having said that let's
get right into it so here's what we're
looking at number one by
administration makes the move to go
electric
vehicles that's the direction they're
going to that's what they want people to
do
and remember that he has control by
creating
additional taxes to influence you to get
away
from gasoline-powered vehicles so now
that's the administration now you have
to realize that car
auto manufacturers make decisions based
on having lobbyists that are working
with the government
whispering to them you better get away
from oil
gasoline-powered cars because eventually
we may
ban it could that really happen now
let's take a look i don't want to
speculate
let's take a look so here's what we're
looking at all the promises automakers
have made about
electric cars so gm releases their new
two chevrolet bolt is what you're
looking at here february 14 2021
jaguars talking about that's the
direction they're going to go in 2022
mercedes is coming out with their eqs by
the end of the year in 2022 ford intends
to start production of
f-150 lightning which is an electric
version of america's best-selling
vehicle by the spring of
2022 here's honda talking about their
cars mazda's planning on coming out with
theirs
nissan eight evs by the end of the year
in 2023 and 2024 land rover is going to
be all electric vehicle cars that
they're coming out with volvo's
announcing theirs by 2024
2025 audi plans on having 30 electrified
vehicles by 2025
20 those models will be evs bmw
said as early as 2017 it expects to have
hybrid and electric vehicles to account
for 15 to 20
of its global sales by 2025. ford says
it's investing 25 29 million dollars
billion dollars into it this continues
hyundai
you know toyota plans to launch 60 new
hybrid cars is what they're talking
about
volkswagen is talking about one and a
half million vo
i mean i can go on and on and on so why
are they going in that direction watch
this one here
by 2030 a uk ban
on the sale of diesel and gas powered
cars
is expected to go into effect let me
read this to you one more time
by 20 2030 a uk ban on the sale of
diesel
and gas powered cars so imagine i make
cars
they're diesel and gas powered and i
want to sell it
in uk it's a waste of time to produce it
because it's going to be banned because
nobody can sell it so the government
is controlling what manufacturers are
going to make with their cars
huh mitsubishi is planning on having 50
of its sales
being from electric and electric or
hybrid cars right
volkswagen's targeting 60 of the
european market
this i can go on and on and on talking
about what these guys gonna be doing
right
you can read this article i'll put the
link below now let's take a look at the
most
expensive and cheapest gas prices
worldwide if you're taking a
look at this here here's as of yesterday
as recent as yesterday cheapest gas
right now if you want to buy
per gallon it's in venezuela you know
how much it is
seven cents yes seven cents you know
what country in the world has the most
oil it's venezuela not saudi arabia
not iran it's venezuela look at iran 23
cents
look at kuwait a buck 30 nigeria buck 54
iraq buck 94 you go down qatar
two two dollars and seven cents we go to
azerbaijan 227 colombia 228
saudi arabia 232 dubai 242
russia 254 let's see where the u.s is at
turkey is 348 u.s
347. now let's go to the bottom let's go
all the way to the bottom
most expensive you ready hong kong
9.67 a gallon
lebadon 870 netherlands
817 norway 798 denmark
759 a gallon is what we're talking about
israel 756 portugal
750 greece finland sweden they're all
over seven italy france uk
everybody i said outside of uk is over
seven dollars uk is
6.95 now these are
gasoline price per gallon gas
in these countries right now let's look
at the top 10
greenest countries in the world greenest
countries
in the world if you can see this data
let me make it a little larger for you
number one denmark has the highest score
of 82 and a half
huh let's see where denmark scores on
the highest gas prices
do you notice a correlation there it's
interesting
go green don't buy gas because we're
going to raise taxes so you don't buy it
it's going to be expensive
if you want to buy it from us you think
that'll motivate if gas prices were 7
59 right now and you're living in
totally though
you're living in miami chicago l.a would
you maybe be inspired to go buy an ev
vehicle fairly quickly would you you
don't think this may be something
they're talking about and seeing it
in the administration we got to kind of
get away get away from to buy these
other cars
let's continue that's just one country
maybe i'm just speculating luxembourg
the second largest country in the world
when it talks about going green
where are they at on this ranking are
they cheap nope
six bucks okay maybe that's just two of
them how about switzerland uk
you already know where uk is at 695.
switzerland 657 france
austria let's look at france and austria
here's france seven dollars
austria uh it's a little cheaper for you
576.
do you want me to continue do you kind
of by the way you do this with every one
of them norway germany sweden
finland they're all on the same list are
they trying to drive people away
from that now if we look at gas prices
history-wise here's what you're looking
at how much gas prices were
i was in the army in 1999 when gas
prices were 98 cents a gallon 96 cents a
gallon 98 cents a gallon
cheaper than what it was in 1993 and in
gas prices if you remember it peaked
around four dollars
in 2008 414 and got a little bit higher
in the threes and then came back down
from 2016 it was buck 87
you know it was buck 98 buck 93 no one's
really been too stressed out about gas
prices
today if you look at gas prices memorial
day weekend 2021 about a month and a
half ago
who are the states with the highest gas
prices pennsylvania 315 then you got
idaho illinois alaska utah
oregon washington nevada hawaii anybody
surprised that california's
4 16. by the way is it 416 because
that's the price of gas
or is it 416 because the state of
california added a gas
tax to it so where am i going with this
here's where i'm going with this
countries with oil consumption us is the
highest
more than anybody else then it's china
then it's india
these guys have five times the amount of
population as we do
we consume more gas than they do matter
of fact
world consumption of gas oil
is united states 20 we have 330 million
people 340 million people 8 billion
people in the world
of which 20 of all the oil is going
through us
and in 2019 we became the first time
where we're energy independent
since 1957. we're using
less oil than we're actually producing
we're independent of that right so we're
kind of going that direction this was
good news that came out
but let me continue with my idea here
with gas prices why do i think gas price
is going to go up
think about it this way current
administration wants to push you
to go by eevee whether you agree with
that or not it's go
green it's climate change it saved the
planet
it's you know we have to drive
electrical vehicles manufacturers are
responding to that
so if you were on their campaign if you
were on their administration
how would you suggest doing this there's
really two ways of doing it
one is pain one is pleasure pleasure is
what
if you go get an ev vehicle we're going
to give you ten thousand dollar
write-off if you buy a brand new car
okay so it's pleasure i'm gonna get a
write-off i'm gonna get tax benefits i'm
gonna get this i'm gonna get that
or they can do the other way which
historically many politicians have used
which is what
it's called pain and how do you do it
with pain it's called sin taxes
what are sin taxes syntaxes we have on
sugar
on cigarettes on alcohol on soft drinks
on casinos on porn literally porn
i can go on and on and on and tell you
all these different syntaxes
what if the administration sat there and
they said you know what
how soon do we want everybody to go to
ev what if somebody like an aoc makes
the phone call and says hey
if you really think this is that big of
a deal why don't you put a three dollar
tax
a four dollar tax a five dollar tax on
anybody that
goes and buys gas prices gas cars
now they can't do it suddenly because if
they did there'd be a strike
and it'd be the ugliest thing they could
do but could they gradually
turn the knob to create the kind of
pressure for you where at the dinner
you're sitting with the family you're
talking saying babe i don't know if
you're what just happened right now
what's that
i think it's time we go buy that tesla i
think we go buy that ev i think we go
buy that electrical vehicle
so what does this mean long term if you
thought the stocks
of these electrical vehicle companies
are going to go up whoever's got the
biggest market share take a tesla if you
think they were maybe going to go up
the direction politics is going and the
direction
how they can influence that based on
what many european countries are doing
to control people from not driving
oil and gasoline-powered vehicles we may
be going in that direction
could it happen in the next two years at
10 i don't know but all i can say to you
is
what we're currently looking at if the
administration
really wanted to push all of us to go in
that direction
they could probably do it in many
different ways pain or pleasure
you may agree with this you may not
agree with this again if you do agree
with this
thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
you don't put your thumbs down but if
you want to find out a little bit more
on topics like this i did a video a
month ago
on specifically the topic of inflation
which a lot of people are talking about
when inflation does happen who wins and
how do we come up with this concept of
inflation
what triggers inflation going up if
you've never watched that video
click over here to watch that video take
everybody bye